[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for
e.t colin also mac and me
um i'm here with lon harris and joe
starr
danielle's off this week she'll be back
next time but we're talking about
uh one of the all-time great movies one
of the all-time worst we're going to be
watching our own trailer for it giving
you some behind-the-scenes thoughts
after that we're going to show you some
deleted scenes and respond to questions
from viewers like you
and finally tease next week's honest
trailer it's going to be a good one
if you're watching uh this is the second
time you're watching last week i teased
uh next week's one by mistake
so the clue didn't make any sense this
week
but it made sense for last week so i
guess this week i'll
clue the two weeks from now on his
trailer yeah now we're not like we're
never getting out of this now
it's on screen we'll put time codes in
we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out uh so what do you
guys think about et
it's um i'll i'll just start off by
saying i think it's
as close to a perfect movie as you'll
find and uh i had nothing to say about
it so we talked about mac and me instead
i was wondering how you were gonna fit
these two together when we were you were
just like
send me notes about e.t and mac and me
without unpacking
how they interlocked so uh yeah
it was fun to see how it all sort of
came together
yeah uh uh this is a
pretty perfect movie i agree uh i
just have really enjoyed the process of
uh for months now this has just been a
sparkle in spencer gilbert's eye
where he wrote e.t but also mac and me
on a dry erase board
and it's been exciting to watch it come
together
i mean i just had a hunch that uh
e.t like sure we could you know crank
off e.t
um which is a whole different movie uh
for
for five minutes and just talk about how
amazing it is and how it's like uh
it's like a children's book come to life
with these amazing visuals and the score
and the best child acting and it's so
cohesive and just all comes together but
like
we're a comedy show so what are we gonna
make jokes about uh and that's where
mac came along which i've actually never
seen i just kind of wanted to watch
mac and me for the first time he just
wanted an excuse for hacking me
i guess oh boy
that was lon you pointed out in your
notes is like how
something can be so similar and yet so
different
with when it comes to technique or
execution yeah
i mean actually mac and me i think is a
really great it highlights exactly what
is so special about what spielberg can
do
and how it's so it's so delicately
balanced because eating
is kind of gross and monstrous like it's
not
cute in the traditional sense and and
like
so it's back like mcafee tries to kind
of do the same thing
but it just stays monstrous and
disgusting the whole time through
it never becomes endearing at all uh and
it's just like every single thing like
that like all the subtle delicate
things that spielberg is doing if you
don't have such a deft
spielbergian touch it slides right into
mac and me
yeah i think it really speaks to what
spielberg was able to do with this
uh because you know like we say et is a
horrific
uh nightmare creature most
movies like this have to cheat uh baby
yoda is adorable stitch is adorable
um they're all there's something cute
about all there's nothing cute about e.t
like he just looks like uh you put a
bunch of worthers originals together
and then microwaved them for a minute
like that's what mbt looks like
um and yeah and the fact that he's able
to
instantly make you empathize with this
with this creature
and it's a great movie yeah yeah it's
like
spielberg gets that it's about it's not
about hijinks there are hijinks like
get kids getting drunk and oh we gotta
hide you in the closet for mom like that
happens
but it's really it's about vulnerability
like that's what
elliott and e.t share and that's what
their bond is based on is like
they need each other like the world is
kind of out to get both of them
and mcamee just does not
really pay attention to that or think
about it's just like whoa there was an
alien around lots of crazy stuff would
happen right
yeah you'd probably go to mcdonald's i
mean the other genius thing is like the
that spielberg is doing so much of the
work just visually
just with visual metaphor and he's not
explaining how it happens he's showing
you how everything happens
uh it's it's what you're not seeing
that's uh
that's more exciting or scary or
whatever the emotion is he wants to feel
than what he's actually showing you or
telling you
like just the key the the bad guy having
like uh keys on his belt like that's all
you get
that's so much more menacing than like a
guy in power armor or something or like
a government agent
saying i'm going to get you e.t yeah
well because it's told from
so much of that is uh and just another
brilliant part about it is that so much
of it is from elliot's point of view and
like those are the things that a kid
would remember like
the i can't remember those key like a
kid wouldn't remember a menacing speech
yeah yeah it's like from a kid's point
of view it does i think i said up top
like it does feel like
like a children's book come to life um
that gets them out of like there isn't a
ton of like mythology there's not a lot
of world building it's really like a lot
of like here
it's the superficial situation like here
it is we got to get him here we got to
do this like
they're just figuring out the basics
whereas something i was just watching
not long ago
monster squad which is another movie
where it's like kids on sort of a
supernatural adventure but there's so
many like rules we got to get the amulet
and this we gotta open the portal and
that's what dracula wants and it's just
like man has nards
yeah you spent half the movie describing
how the wolf man has
nards and you don't need to and that
like that's the time et doesn't bother
with it's just with the kids
and with them bonding with et and
learning about et
you don't have to worry about all of
that exposition they saved the lord for
the botanicus book
oh yeah definitely right yeah something
the green planet was it
yeah the green planet yeah uh and then
yeah the john williams score
is is fantastic i was surprised mac and
me uh
score alan silvestri the marvel guy yeah
you know he slumbed it okay she didn't
pay the bills
look even williams did the patriot okay
like sometimes you gotta
sometimes you gotta slum it isn't the
patriot just like the national anthem
but louder
lots of bugles there was a big bugle
section
uh all right let's watch uh our odds
trailer for
e.t mac and me
this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers
that works on every possible level to
create an all-time classic fill
[Music]
hey stay focused that was for mac and me
pause makami gets his
ish rocked throughout the entire film
he gets run over he gets electrocuted he
gets sucked into like a million vacuums
um i thought i guess they were going for
more of a slapstick thing but it's just
like yeah it's like
looney tunes rules literally aliens play
by like roger rabbit
toontown like they could peel themselves
off of things
and explode
uh anyways um walking the one shot
that's super disturbing like
legitimately in mcamee is when they
explode
and then the whole alien family just
staggers like the terminator out of the
flames we put a little bit of it in the
trailer
like that's how did they not realize
that that looks terrifying and sinister
like a heart yeah and then when the
cops like basically kill the main
character
i'm not steeped in mac and me lore but i
would love to know
what they thought they were making
because you know like
the people that made money playing
didn't think they were making money
playing they thought they were making
something
dope uh uh and they did
but you know what i'm saying like what
was the intention
yeah i think they knew they were making
e.t i think that it was one of those
things where um
we can get in a little bit to the story
of mac and me where like the guy
whoever created it had this idea that he
was like
he brought it to mcdonald's and like the
idea was that like okay we could make a
movie
that would fund like the ronald mcdonald
children's charities and stuff like that
and we're gonna cast a disabled actor
like
it's gonna be great and they didn't have
a script
exactly when it got greenlit and it was
like it's gonna be like et was how they
sold it and then
it's just like okay what's like e.t
how about this um e.t
let's just do e.t so i think good
intentions it was like a grift but for
charity
that works for the best kind of gift
except that
all right let's keep going e.t
the extraterrestrial get on your bikes
and ride for one of the most uplifting
stories ever told about a co-dependent
relationship
where a stranded alien stalks a child
[Music]
forges a physical emotional link without
his consent
and puts him through unfathomable pain
unless he helps him go home
he needs to go to be fair
uh i think you're you also talked about
this long as um
that e.t didn't have to keep going after
elliott like
yeah well here's my question is e.t a
child from his planet because i think
we're we're sort of
supposed to assume that but it's never
made clear
i think in the green planet
uh yeah i think he's yeah i think he's a
kid
or not at least right a student person
we know he's a boy they make a
they make a point of saying he's a boy
like right
okay so if so if i think if if e.t is
very
young then this is more forgivable then
he just like sees a kid and he's just
like oh i'm gonna
this kid's got to help me i'm stranded
or whatever he's like over
i think he's over like age 15 in alien
years this is inappropriate like
try to find somebody else this kid can't
help you he's he can barely help himself
i like this movie more if he's an old
hobo yeah
and he's just like i'm gonna skip my
emotions in this little boy like it's so
weird on the shed that said food and
shelter here
it was carved into the fence post that's
a binding contract
a kind man lives here he's been riding
the rails like
the alien hobos
one of his salad fingers has like the
sack on it like
yeah yeah the bindle yeah he's asking an
awful lot of this like random boy who
just wanted to be like helpful and give
him a few reese's pieces
yeah no that's a that's like a big ass
chewbacca like
uh life contract what what's that thing
yeah
when wookies don't leave
i like the idea that chewbacca was like
matt foley from the snl sketch like
we're a bunker brother
it's also that's also morgan freeman in
uh in prince of thieves he's like well
you saved my life so now i'm following
you to england then kevin costa's like
that's okay you don't need to come to
england
all the demands that i come to england
with you and live in your house
we were in that hole together han so
yeah wait they were in chewbacca and han
were in a hole together and
yeah so we're uh robin hood and morgan
freeman
and nazeem yeah kazeem yeah they're they
uh
all these deaths same backstory that's
whole law yeah
uh okay enough whole talk let's keep
watching as bad as that can be aliens
those things are just monsters
[Music]
sorry just can't stop thinking about mac
and me movie really sticks with you
follow along with this ugly old wrinkly
trashcan looking ass alien
that pulls off the impossible trick of
making you love him despite his horrible
face
and disgustingly long salad fingers then
once you're done
should we explain for the uninitiated
what salad fingers was is that
i hope people get what that is yeah that
was one of those that i used to think
was too
old uh reference but then when we
started to get uh
like walton references back and people
upset with us
i was like well go for it then i guess
they know salad fingers cell figures is
like
before they even had a term of like was
it creepypasta
it was just like just a weird flash
animation of like
which is all you needed back then you
needed something like a quarter funny or
a quarter scary
and you could rule the internet in 2000
yeah
like right it looked like it was going
to be funny and then it was just creepy
and off-putting
yeah uh something about rusty spoons um
but uh yeah yeah uh i i think we it's in
a deleted scene but his fingers are
actual fleshlights
it's gross uh okay keep going long salad
fingers
then once you learn to look past all
that and open your heart
watch him slowly die and i mean die die
like put him in a bag the only thing
that could have been more of a gut punch
is that they killed his entire family
something that i didn't even make it
into a into a draft but i'm looking at
my notes now
could have been funny but very
complicated to explain is like
what if et wasn't an alien like you cut
like
out from the perspective and it turns
out like like a life of pie style it
turns out it's just like
an old guy who shows up and gets really
high and
moves in with the kid and takes apart
his speaking spell and tries to call an
alien and then
then wakes up naked in a ditch down by a
river
and this is all his dream i thought you
were gonna do like drop dead fred like
what if he's only in eliot's mind and
this is just elliot doing all of this
stuff
well you've been advocating for a drop
dead fred on australia for a while now
and i have
i think that'll be our final episode
it's how we say goodbye to the format is
dropped good friend you can't
you can't carry on after that no that's
it
uh all right let's keep going
enjoy this simple film told with such
detail craft and subtlety
it's become an iconic text about
childhood and while mac and me is also
about a stranded alien who provides a
child with a name that starts with e who
lives in california with a hard-working
single mother and an older brother named
michael who's lured out of hiding by a
trail of snacks left by a boy who stays
home sick from school and when the
government is on his tail they dress him
up in a costume leading agents to chase
the kid through the neighborhood but the
mom sells them out then the kid almost
dies until the alien heals him the
difference is
e.t is good pause
uh before we get into mcdonald's i just
uh a shout out to our epic voice guy
who always who who always refuses to uh
when we're like hey man you can just
take the sentence by sentence and he's
like no
i am an artist and a craftsman and i
will do that entire thing in one take
and uh just props to that there john
bailey
yeah and it works it makes it it makes
it like you get the joke
better because it's all this one crazy
block of text yeah we don't fix it in
post this is
this is the raw audio yeah i also want
to say
that whole sequence is built on the idea
that they had a like
teddy bear costume that was max sized
just sitting around like in e.t they
throw a sheet over him and it's
halloween it makes perfect sense and
it's halloween
in this one it's not halloween and
they're just he's walking around with a
an alien-sized teddy bear who's in like
a hollowed out like why did they have
that teddy bear with a leftover
halloween costume i've seen some pretty
horrifying uh homemade because
it's just like a stuffed bear because
he's there's that scene where he's like
uh his neighbor's mom is driving them
around and he's like
well it's one of those brand new bears
and she's like that's actually old and
ratty and he's like
i modified it with a computer okay
but that's what i originally thought too
but so what did he run inside and real
quick
unstuff his bears yeah it could work as
a copy
the skin of a real bear and you just
didn't deleted that scene
matt just ate a bear and then pulled the
skin out like a like a cartoon
with a salmon bone and his parents were
like now you are safe
then put it on okay keep going
arne mcamee has an eight minute long
dance sequence in a mcdonald's
your hero is in a wheelchair why would
you do this
just talk about the mcdonald's-ness of
it all um there's a few
other like mcdonald's drops through here
and there of like what are you
thinking like i want a big mac like just
lines here there but then
yeah the movie is like it's kind of an
uninspired
like kind of a sleepy riff on e.t
until it gets to this mcdonald's and
then like you can tell
everyone just got really excited to be
at a mcdonald's because the film it like
the pace of it
quickens up and there's like everyone's
dead there's multiple dance numbers
there's one going on in the parking lot
yeah one going on inside
the birthday party is like the coolest
thing in the world like they're
everything is just popping off and i
don't know i feel like this was just
made by somebody who genuinely loved
mcdonald's
ronald mcdonald is there oh my god
nuts in there and and i believe it was
pretty much just like that
it had everything kind of feels like
it's
overselling it's overselling the
mcdonald's experience a little like if
you were a kid
and you watch this movie you're like oh
my god we have to get to mcdonald's
instantly enjoying the party
a regular neighborhood mcdonald's is
going to be a letdown
oh my yeah like ronald mcdonald was
doing like bottle service
for your table yeah no he's coming over
with sparklers in your big bag
it was nuts they can't maintain this
level
yeah a huge indoor dance contest as as
you do
look guys you know disparage it all you
want all i'm gonna say is
uh my mcdonald's birthday party uh we
we it got buck wild um hey
i ate mad fries and a sheet cake with
grimace on it and then i got into the
play place and had that hamburger thing
and we spun the wheel it made the
hamburger spin and i did that too much
and i threw up it was a dope
really fun pretty was jennifer aniston
possibly okay uncredited
yeah and uncredited jen aniston at the
mcdonald's and mac and me apparently
that's what we learned
making this all right let's let's keep
watching
you do this so whether you want a
children's fantasy come to life in a
groundbreaking work of movie magic
or the movie equivalent of your mom
buying you the wrong toy for christmas
the film that gave us the breakout role
for drew barrymore or the first role of
jennifer aniston
guys i'm not lying is that her i think
check out either the film that should
have won best picture that year or the
film that had a profit sharing agreement
with the charity but flopped so hard
they couldn't pay them a cent
no no you will not yeah pause let's see
the
the the oscars that year i know it lost
to gandhi
which i think i think et's a better
movie than gandhi
although i will say this uh both gandhi
and mac and me uh
movies i was shown in school oh okay yes
same
wait no i never saw mac school but i saw
gandhi you guys never watched meh
what was mac and me being shown in
school for we had like a weird rainy day
where it was just like i'm putting on a
movie
and we watch mac and me nice
educational but don't you think that
like
out of uh let's see what else was up
there
gandhi i know this is fascinating
television
um well gandhi is the sort of movie that
it's like it's it's very like
handsomely produced like it's big and
epic but
i know it was those kinds of hollywood
epics have sort of fallen out of fashion
also not casting an indian person as
gandhi sort of
right tootsie's good uh
the but same same thing with gandhi uh
missing and the verdict
i'm going with e.t i'm going to tt yeah
i'll go deep
you know what i i mistook apparently uh
ben kingsley i was not 100
uh is of indian descent so i i oh no way
take that back yeah also in mac and me
also in an uncredited role
he's the [ __ ] he's mac he's playing mac
and mac
mac hates the boy yeah
uh good times all right let's keep going
but
story drew barrymore
representation for the disabled
community misrepresentation of native
americans
that's like bang bang the introductions
of these characters it was like oh wow
uh our hero is uh is handicapped that's
like that's a cool choice for
a movie in 1983. and literally like the
next shot is this little white girl
comes out of a teepee with an iguana in
her hair
and starts talking about like chief what
what's it called it's like
oh her bit is really weird her bit is
like oh they're in california now and
everybody's like a hippie
and so her she's like a new age little
girl that's like her
that's her runner it's such an odd thing
for like a seven-year-old
it wasn't like young gwyneth paltrow
but it does also shine a light on how
good the acting
is from the kids in e.t like oh man
elliot and like drew barrymore is like
just adorable in every single thing
and the older brother that they cast as
perfect as like just the jerkwad
older brother and man they caught
lightning in a bottle because mac and me
yeah it's still got that that 70s it's
very like naturalistic it really feels
like a room full of
people that age rather than like a bunch
of kids giving like precocious kid
performances
yeah which is all right yeah
all right keep going
that one is probably the lowest ratio
of uh lowest possible audience for a
joke that we've ever made
because a local southern california car
dealership jingle
keys on van nuys uh i'm sorry i don't
have keys on van nuys where you're from
i'm sorry that's one for us uh
yeah i'm excited to work toyota of
orange into next weeks
you won't get 11. we won't get 11. i
wouldn't have got 11.
toyota of orange so look we should at
least try to do
if nationwide get in for like a sit and
sleep reference they've got locations in
several states you're killing me larry
yeah regional jokes only from now on
yeah wow
she probably should have left that one
for the outtakes but oh well
no i really liked it it's very funny i
would have been i actually would have
been really
uh disappointed in you if that had not
made the cut
i don't cow to the pressure of nobody
else understanding a joke
inside jokes are the funniest ones yeah
uh sorry people all right let's keep
going how to disguise your stunt man
botanicus is that you a literal
flashlight
[Music]
maroon with children a wrinkle and slime
and feed us the slack john yokel
[Music]
we're tween hungerford
it's pretty much flawless here we'll
leave you with a deleted ant-man seat
from avengers in-game
cool so we had to acknowledge the origin
of
uh trolling people with mac and me the
great paul red i'm conan o'brien
i hope they never stop doing that it's a
great fit
yeah this was because so i saw mac and
me in school years ago
and i i just have flashes in my memory
of like an
alien in a teddy bear suit dancing at a
mcdonald's which is the worst version of
weapon x
uh memory implants possible but
i didn't it wasn't until paul rudd
started doing that bit that i was like
oh my god that's the thing and that's
what made it
all come flooding back which was uh
which was traumatic but also cheaper
than therapy
so oh there you go uh
all right so that's mac and me um let's
take a moment
to uh thank this audience that is
currently with us
uh and tell them to subscribe for our
channel
i'm very bad at reading scripts
subscribe to our channel for vids every
weekday
hit that like hit that bell you like
this you click those things get more of
it it's that simple people
um we also have a fandom five trivia
show coming up this friday on friends
if you have wasted your life watching
friends and if you've watched friends
you have
uh go on this trivia show and win real
money to answer questions about
all of your favorite friends ross
joseph just kim only
good friend look if you can't tell i'm
more of a seinfeld guy but you should
click the link in the description
because i know friends is incredibly
popular and incredibly beloved uh
from people from roxy's dryer to my
mother
uh everybody loves friends so click on
them click on that link
do that trivia win some actual money
with your friends knowledge
uh yeah sounds like plan let's do it and
then
we now have for you some e.t slash mac
and me
deleted scenes or the film that had a
profit sharing agreement with the
charity but flopped so hard they
couldn't pay them a cent
[Music]
yeah only if burger king gets really
desperate
starring can you hear me now good
understated cool villains over explained
lame villains
the clumps mike carlson
space worm gym the waddle boy
and a goat fiend he took my coke mom
the muppet movies i'm a mac
and i'm an e.t that's really good
hey mac and me you suck
[Music]
yeah they repeatedly sucked him up yeah
it's
a very bad design for your spacecraft to
have a vacuum tube that just sucks up
anything on an
alien planet it breaks that's how you
get xenomorphs guys
that is that's what a terrible adventure
like oh we're just gonna send it down to
an alien world it'll just vacuum up
anything and bring it back to earth
where we can study it
yeah um julia that that starring thing
of like underexplained over explained um
i feel like we didn't subject people to
the
eight-minute long sequence in mac and me
of like everybody who works at nasa
taking apart a spaceship
just step by step like yeah oh my god is
anything going to happen
in this movie because they're just going
through the checklist of how to take
apart a spaceship
it's so weird because et of course opens
with you know like you get the the
little bit of the aliens arriving and
then it's the kids because they're what
matters you get the plain d and d elliot
feels left out you get all that
mcamee jumps right into a bunch of
scientists standing around like there's
no time to get to know
the actual protagonist until like 10
minutes into the movie
yeah gotta show how the spaceship was
taken apart otherwise kids are gonna ask
how did that happen um okay
let's talk about uh some fan comments
okay how about that
uh maurice who says so those so those
takes are like epic voice guys version
of a daredevil hallway fight
yes yep yeah pretty much i'm trying to
think of what some of the longer ones
are
i think he did a real long run on for uh
obviously for in one of the oscars yeah
that was good
um and i feel like the one for jupiter
ascending where he just describes the
plot of jupiter ascending
was like like two pages straight of uh
without a pause of dialogue uh
hard body 217 i'm getting the feeling
they wanted to do a mac me on this
trailer and package it inside e.t
give this guy a non-monetary prize
let's see uh rob turner in my head
cannon the director was with his mates
and they got drunk and said i have an
idea for a film and didn't realize
they'd done an e.t with product
placement
like they did it would be amazing it
didn't mean amazing if you made this
whole film and you hadn't seen the et
and then somebody was like hey
this movie that just came out is pretty
similar to mac and me you should check
it out
yeah you're like what oh crap
what have we done well at least it isn't
some famous director
who also had the same idea it was who
um disney fan writes alan silvestri did
also did a lilo and stitch yeah and a
ton of things he did forrest gump he did
back to the future
kid gets an alien friend yeah
that's his specialty gotta call out
um we okay phillip a uh democrats
we failed to mention et the greatest
console game of all time hashtag atari
will rise again
oh yeah
they buried all of those uh i've played
the et video game
it is that it is really really atrocious
it is terrible uh but i think the focus
on how terrible it is overlooks the fact
that like
so many old atari games from that era
were terrible like there
there there were a few really great ones
and then most of them are
equally terrible yeah uh but they hadn't
like banked so much on
e.t on those yeah right and et is
particularly bizarre because they're
occasionally trying to work in
stuff remove like there's a flower in a
pot in it so you're like well that's
from e.t
but the game itself has nothing to do
with the moon
also seeing some people talking about uh
how he didn't bring up the
star wars references in et and uh i will
right now there are star wars references
in e.t
yeah yoda masked guy i hope you're happy
sometimes it's it's not that we forgot
it's that we said
everyone is aware of this and uh or
we cut it for time well that also et is
like in
star wars at some point yeah yeah and
then but then also yoda is an e.t
yeah that they uh they they nod to each
other
caitlyn writes i haven't seen it since i
was a kid but i didn't like e.t the mind
control
at the school sequence was horrifying to
me i thought it was really
yeah if you think about it it's
horrifying but it's i thought it was
sweet
uh uh just watching it happen the first
time
like with the freeing all the frogs and
like doing the like
old-timey spin dance moves with the kids
like it was very schmaltzy but but
spielberg pulls it off it does still
raise the question though of like
if does et understand that this is going
to happen
or is this is this just like accidental
like oh i bonded with that
kid oh no now he's gonna get drunk when
i get drunk because otherwise it's your
response
i think he's doing it just out of like
an instinct you know like those um
it's like the last of us those things
that they're based on where like those
they like it's that bug that goes inside
the ant's brain and makes it crawl up
to like the highest branch and then like
uh something sprouts out of its head and
he is a clicker yeah e.t is a clicker
basically
he's he's he's implanted himself in this
boy and he's going to
uh puppet him to ride into the woods and
build a telephone
i'm going with uh with y'all's theory
now that e.t is actually just an
old uh real ride and hobo name like ed
tarterton
and i'm gonna put my son behind in this
boy
these kids are going to get me out of a
comfortable crowd
the keys guy is just the irs
oh man too bad they didn't make a sequel
to this i'm sure they did somewhere oh
what the sequel was going to be
horrifying have you ever read the
treatment for the sequel
no go and read it and it's okay
it's a horrible nightmare all right it's
yeah it's like just like a full gore
house weird
yeah we're gonna make a gory sequel to
e.t
yeah it was it's it's a nightmare fest
they were gonna temple of doom
e.t yes cool what is it is interesting
that the end of et
is it's sort of the reversal of close
encounters like close encounters ends
with the guy
like the alien is like hey come screw
humans come with me to space
and richard dreyfuss is like yeah forget
my family i'm coming with the aliens
and i i almost feel like silver got a
lot of crap about it from
his family and he's like no
now we're against that now elliot's got
to stay at home with his mom
he can't go would you get on the ship
lon
do i have elliot's like like crummy home
life or am i like doing okay
uh no you're yeah you're dead because
i'm like miserable like ellie and i'm
like super alone and everybody
kind of hates me and my dad's in mexico
or whatever like yeah i'm probably
getting hot
you have a darker read on elliot's life
than me i i mean look
there the dad ran out on him but like
it's a loving family the mom's doing the
best she can okay
yeah no it's not that hard because he's
you know he's really lonely that's like
the whole
setup of the movie is like he doesn't
feel like he's got anybody
you know that he can sort of talk to and
be with except this uh
you know wrinkle monster from the stars
and uh that's the inciting incident
so you're getting on the short and
getting on the ship with ed tarkington
oh botanicus is the main draw i want to
hang out with you
yeah um would you remember when we did
the uh what were those
little cartoons we did after credits
after card remember the et one where
everyone just got murdered
uh oh yeah cause that was like a loving
homage to the treatment for et2 yeah we
didn't know their
intentions maybe we'll do a table read
of that someday
uh someday when tables are permitted by
law again
[Laughter]
yeah i'm sorry i'm now reading the
script of the after credits one
we were talking about zerek et's uh
brodo egosian nom de plume
zerek z-r-e-k look it up that's real
now i'm here to turn your planet red
with blood okay anyways we'll do that on
a different video
thank you guys for watching honest
trailer commentaries we'll be back next
week
with uh you know i'll just tease next
week's again
um and uh and you guys can hopefully
figure it out from this
um it's uh i think i'll say the same
thing which is
this is a movie that you're going to
want to know more about um
and that's all you get and we'll see you
then thank you guys for watching
[Music]
bye
you